>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: 100 DAYS INTO TOTAL
DEMOCRAT CONTROL OF D.C. AND
IT'S APPARENT WHO JOE BIDEN'S
MAIN BOOSTER IS.
THE U.S. MEDIA OF COURSE.
COMPARE THEIR TREATMENT OF JOE
BIDEN'S FIRST 100 DAYS VERSUS
DONALD TRUMP.
HERE IS NO AT 100.
>> WHETHER OR NOT YOU LIKE THE
POLICY IT'S BEEN AN
EXTRAORDINARY FIRST 100 DAYS.
>> HE IS TRYING TO BUILD AND
SUSTAIN POLITICAL MOMENTUM FOR
HIS APPROACH TO SAY WE HAVE DONE
IT FOR THE FIRST -- IN TERMS OF
TH PANDEMIC.
>> BRING DOWN THE TEMPERATURE IN
AN OVER-HEATED WASHINGTON
INFLAMED BY DONALD TRUMP.
>> Laura: NOW COMPARE THE FAWN
FEST FOR BIDEN TO WHAT THEY DID
TO DONALD TRUMP.
>> THE FIRST 100 DAYS
A DISASTER.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE THERE IS A LOT
OF FAILURE DOMESTICALLY.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS NO
LEGISLATIVE ACHIEVEMENT AT ALL.
AT RECORD LOW APPROVAL RATINGS.
>> Laura: YOU COULD FEEL THE
LOVE.
NEWT GINGRICH, THEY HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN IN THE TANK THE DEMOCRATS.
IT'S GOTTEN TO THE POINT THEY
ARE ADVANCING BOTH DANGEROUS AND
ANTI-CONSTITUTION, ANTI-AMERICAN
POLICIES AT THE SAME TIME.
>> SURE, BUT THAT'S BEEN THE
NATURAL EVOLUTION OF THE MODERN
AMERICA NEWS MEDIA.
THEY STARTED ON THE LEFT.
THEY HAVE GONE FURTHER TO THE
LEFT.
THEY HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO EVEN
AOC HAS SAID HAS BEEN MORE
RADICAL THAN SHE COULD HAVE
HOPED FOR.
THEY HAD 100 DAYS THAT ARE THE
MOST RADICAL 100 DAYS OF ANY
PRESIDENT IN MODERN TIMES, MAYBE
IN HISTORY, UNLESS YOU COUNT
LINCOLN'S PRESIDING OVER THE
BEGINNING OF THE CIVIL WAR AND A
LOT OF THEIR RECORD IS
A DISASTER.
WE HAVE HAD MORE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN THE FIRST 3 MONTHS
OF BIDEN THAN IN ALL OF LAST
YEAR.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
IN ONE QUARTER, WE PASSED LAST
YEAR'S TOTAL FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
WE HAD THE LARGEST INCREASE IN
MURDERS.
YOU COVERED IT BRILLIANTLY
EARLIER.
WE HAD A HUGE INCREASE IN
SHOOTINGS THAT ARE NOT FATAL.
A HUGE INCREASE IN CARJACKINGS
AND RAPES.
WE HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION IN
TERMS OF BASIC POLICIES IS DOING
EVERYTHING IT CAN TO UNDERMINE
AND WEAKEN AMERICA.
ALMOST NONE OF THAT IT WILL BE
COVERED BY THE NEWS MEDIA
BECAUSE THEY ARE TOTALLY
COMMITTED TO PROTECTING BIDEN
JUST AS THEY DID FOR THE WHOLE
CAMPAIGN.
THEY DON'T WANT TO REPORT THESE
THINGS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HIS SPEECH.
I AM CURIOUS.
WILL HE DEAL WITH ANYTHING THAT
IS REAL?
OR JUST MORE LEFT WING RHETORIC
TO SET UP ANOTHER LEFT WING
PROGRAM TO SPEND MORE OF THE
TAXPAYER'S MONEY ON LEFT WING
INTEREST GROUPS?
>> Laura: YOU MENTIONED THE
ADDRESS TOMORROW TO CONGRESS
JOINT SESSIONS.
HERE'S HOW THEY DID IT AT MSNBC.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN ADDRESS HIS
FIRST ADDRESS TO THE JOINT
SESSION OF CONGRESS TOMORROW AND
THE WHITE HOUSE TELLS NBC NEWS
HE IS DEEPLY INVOLVED IN ITS
DEVELOPMENT.
>> Laura: DEEPLY INVOLVED.
THEY SAID THAT A LOT ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO WOULD X-OUT
BIG PORTIONS OF HIS REMARKS AND
CHANGE THEM OFF THE CUFF WHEN HE
HAD TO.
>> THE MOST FASCINATING THING TO
ME, AS A FORMER SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, THE MOST FASCINATING
ASPECT OF TOMORROW NIGHT.
THEY WILL ONLY HAVE 200 PEOPLE
IN THE ENTIRE ROOM.
THIS IS A ROOM THAT CAN EASILY
HOLD 1,000 OR MORE PEOPLE.
THEY DECIDED FOR COVID
REASONS -- THIS IS A PRESIDENT
WHOSE PATHOLOGICAL CONCERN ABOUT
COVID IS ALMOST BIZARRE -- FOR
COVID REASONS, 50 HOUSE
REPUBLICANS AND 50 HOUSE
DEMOCRATS, 50 SENATE DEMOCRATS
AND 50 SENATE REPUBLICANS,
THAT'S IT.
IF YOU ARE NOT ON THE INVITATION
LIST, DON'T COME BECAUSE WE
WON'T LET YOU IN.
THIS WILL BE THE WEIRDEST
AMERICAN SPEECH BY A PRESIDENT
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
IT WILL BE A VIRTUALLY EMPTY
ROOM.
YOU HAVE AN EMPTY SYMBOLIC
ADMINISTRATION